vous le savez tout au long du mois
d'octobre france 2 participent à la
mobilisation pour la sauvegarde de
l'environnement mais dans ce domaine
aussi il y à des sujets qui fâchent les
éoliennes par exemple à chaque fois
qu'un parc s'installe une association
d'opposants voit le jour principale
récrimination la pollution visuelle mais
surtout le bruit pourtant les nouvelles
installations ont fait beaucoup de
progrès dans ce domaine reportage à
corentin cantal ou cinq éoliennes ont
semé le vent et récolter la tempête
ville marine et arnaud rist il y avait
un pâturage et puis tout a changé une
autre dimension 146 m 3 mégawatts les
cinq éoliennes les plus hautes et les
plus puissantes de france son fichier
depuis quelques mois dans ce coin de
terre du cantal ça nous enlève nos crête
parce qu'on ne voit plus qu'elle notre
ligne d'horizon et nous les voyons mais
à des kilomètres des kilomètres à la
ronde et on les entend beaucoup trop aux
dires de cette poignée d'opposants qui
nous entraîne au pied d'un film
le bruit est là mais pas assourdissant
ce jour là l'éolienne la plus proche
d'une maison 500 m est en panne un
simple répit selon cet habitant
c'est un bruit fatigue how quoi sans
arrêt sans arrêt qui tourne qui tombe
dit on est tous d'épargné du tarn
du tarn au village pas de bruit au mois
de janvier le gel a fait grincer les
éoliennes durant quatre jours depuis
plus rien l'autoroute toute proche elle
déverse en permanence le bruit du trafic
70 décibels c'est le maximum atteint par
les éoliennes pour le professeur choir
auteur d'un rapport destiné à l'académie
de médecine on est loin des méfaits
causés par les autoroutes aéroports ou
même usage des baladeurs de sons des
bruits qui sont supérieures à à 40 50
décibels qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 70
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec des bruits
de sauver 100 db 2k games oreilles non
ça n'abîme pas l'oreille mais ça ça
fatigue ça mais au sursaut saborder
veille légalement il n'existe pas de
distance à respecter mais la direction
des affaires sanitaires impose
systématiquement 500 m le rapport lui
recommande 1500 mètres trop pour des
opérateurs qui envisage 6000 éoliennes
supplémentaires d'ici 2020 mais à 500 m
il ya vraiment plus aucun bruit du tout
donc aller 1 km 500 ça serait stériliser
nu tilman le territoire tant que c'est
pas acceptable
les 2000 éoliennes déjà en fonction ont
été implantés après enquête publique
étude d'impact notamment sonores il
manque toutefois les résultats d'une
étude globale me actuellement par
l'inserm la première du genre